Now the last few games for those who
have not been present for the last few
speedrun games in the last game
We faced the Karokhan.
I've learned a piece.
I've learned a piece and
Then we managed to recover and win bonus.
Okay, we're wide against decode.
I
Mean again, we've been toggling between
jabal London and 1e4, but let's switch
back
To our main repertoire and go for e4
especially because we're facing the
center counter also known as the
Scandinavian
Which I believe is the first time that
we have faced it in the speedrun.
Okay, Knight f6
This is less popular than Queen takes
d5, which is the sort of more in the
spirit of the Scandi
I don't know if Knight f6 has a name.
Apparently it's called the modern variation.
There is something called the
Portuguese gambit I want to say which
goes d4 Bishop g4, but many years ago
Many many many years ago around 2005
2006 one of my first coaches taught me
a line
That essentially avoids a lot of the
theory of the Portuguese gambit on some
of the trickier lines
And it gives white not as big of an
advantage as you would get if you play
the absolute principled stuff
But what I like is that it just gives
you an easy-to-play position and it
avoids a lot of the theory
So the line goes like this and I've
done this before on a previous speed
run
I remember that we faced this you
deliver a check on b5 which should make
should make a lot of sense to you
It's a developing move and you're
forcing a piece to appear on d7, which
by definition
is severing the connection between the
black Queen and the pawn on d5 and
Fundamentally, there are two approaches
to playing this position.
You could try to cling to the d5 pawn
So what you could try to do here is
play Bishop takes d7 Queen takes d7 and
c4 and a lot of less
Experienced players would gravitate
toward that but I'll show you a couple
of analogs after the game this approach
in many openings
This is not good because after black
plays c6 he attains massive
compensation
Positionally for the pawn in the form
of dominance over key central squares
and it's just not an easy position to
play
So the move that my coach taught me is
to drop the bishop actually back to e2
The point is you give away the d5 pawn
and now you occupy the center with d4
and you get a slight advantage
In an easy-to-play position.
What was the point of this whole
operation with bishop b5 Bishop b2?
Well, it was just a force black's
bishop to appear on d7.
You might say well
Why are we forcing isn't it good for
black to develop a piece?
Well, not quite because the bishop on
d7 is a very awkward piece.
It's again
It's cutting the connection between the
black Queen in the center.
It's preventing the Knight from
accessing that square
It's just not developed on a good
square
So that is why in this line you often
see experienced Scandi players actually
reposition the bishop on f5 c5
I've never seen before it's a very
sensible move
My guess is that if we take on c5 black
wants to give Queen a5 check and then
pick up the pawn and really
Contest our control over the center.
So there are several ways that we can
fight this move
We can ignore it and just keep
developing our pieces
But if possible, I don't just want to
give away our d4 pawn without a fight
now in the allopin cecilian
There is a similar type of idea
that involves pushing c4 and then
driving the pawn into d5 and
establishing a more
A firmer presence in the center, which
I think makes a lot of sense here
I think we should go c4 and counter
attack black's knight
Our opponent is still playing instantly
Which tells me that he proud this is
probably some sort of obscure theory
Now here again d takes c5 is not stupid
Because what we could say is okay,
we're not trying to win a pawn
We're trying to gain a bunch of tempi
for development
After queen a5 check there's one tempo
and then when black takes on c5
There's another tempo we could play
bishop e3 and then essentially complete
our minor piece development with knight
f3
So that I think is a great approach
as well
So I like the look of d takes c5 but d5
is what we initially plan to do
I think we should stick to our guns
here and play d5
e6, okay
So here the instinct of most people I
think is to play knight c3
And then to meet ed with cd
but the problem is that when
That pawn chain turns into an isolated
pawn our strategy loses a lot of its
luster
Because the d5 pawn becomes more of a
liability than a strength
so I think
A more prudent approach here is
actually to take on e6 which I know is
A little bit anticlimactic because we
did all of this and now we're just
giving away our center
But if you look concretely it should
make some more sense de if black plays
fe well, obviously that ruins black
structure
We're happy if black plays bishop takes
e6
Then we're able to trade queens and
force black's king onto a very awkward
square on d8
Which we could use as fuel for our
subsequent development and you should
be familiar with this general concept
where essentially you're able to castle
queen side
With check i'm sure you've probably
done this in other openings and I think
that white has
A very small but a very stable edge in
the end game and we haven't had that
many end games in general
So I wanted an excuse to play an end
game
Okay, clearly this tells me that our
opponent is not in preparation
This is just complete bluff and he's
playing this like a bullet game because
fe is a very bad move.
I think
Now black is saddled with permanent
weakness of the e6 pawn
And of course when black castles king
side the king side is not going to be
quite as safe of a place
As it used to be but let's speed up a
little bit.
I don't want to lose on time
So now
The next stage is for us to just
develop our pieces really in any order
I don't think it particularly matters
in what order we develop our pieces
We do want to protect the d4 square so
that black doesn't quickly establish a
knight on d4
But we just do that by playing knight f3.
Let's start.
Let's start with knight c3.
It doesn't matter
Now we'll play knight f3 gain a little
bit of time and now we'll castle we can
just basically play automatically here
these next couple of moves
But then we should take a moment to
think because this bishop we can
develop it to many different spots and
this is an important decision
Where we develop our bishop?
I see at least four options actually
bishop b3 bishop f4 bishop g5
And let's not forget about the queen
side fianchetto.
We can play b3 and bishop b2
Now let's take the opposite view.
What is black likely to do here?
Well one annoying idea is for black to
try to utilize this pawn effectively to
push it up to e5
And to establish an outpost for the
knight on d4 that is a positional
Weak, well not a weakness, but that is
a risk
That we need to we need to fight.
I I don't I don't think we should allow
black to establish an outpost on d4
Because if we trade on d4 then the pawn
is replaced
The knight is replaced by a very
annoying pawn much like our pawn on d5
and we won't have the machinery
Available to contest that pawn
So for that reason I like bishop f4
because it's prophylactic
Now you might look at this move and say
well
I don't like the fact that we're
stepping into the x-ray of the rook
But an x-ray in and of itself isn't all
that bad.
We have to check to see if black has
discoveries
Unfortunately, I think there is what I
would call a positional discovery
Which is a discovered attack that is
not intended to win a piece.
It is intended to engineer a favorable
trade
By which I mean black has this weird
move knight f6 to e4
And after we take on e4 black is able
to eliminate the dark's court bishop
And make it easier for himself to
secure the knight on d4
So bishop f4 has a bit of a I don't
know whether to call it a tactical or
positional drawback
Let me keep thinking for a minute for a
moment
So if we're not playing bishop f4
We might want to resort to b3.
We also might want to play bishop to e3
Even though it looks a little bit more
passive bishop to g5 is also possible
here
From the perspective of like safest
developing square.
I think let's play bishop g5.
Let's just play the sort of most
Straightforward textbook developing
move and if our opponent plays e5 we'll
cross that bridge when we get there
Okay, obviously bishop h4 is the
typical retreating move
Knight h5 which is I I kind of expected
this actually
Now let's evaluate this positionally
well positionally it leaves black after
the trade of dark squared bishops
Which by the way, we are not forced to
engage and we can drop the bishop back
to g3 people often forget about this
prospect
But the thing is then we give black the
bishop pair and this bishop from e7 can
reposition itself to f6
And again, we're fighting for control
of the d4 square.
That is the sort of
Unstated battle in this position.
So from that perspective we should take
on e7
And here we need to think what does
black want?
Well black wants at least two things
There is this old idea e5 knight d4
It's less scary now because e5 can be
met with knight to d5 and we get an
outpost of our own
The scarier prospect is knight to f4
So you might come up with the idea of
g3, but g3 weakens our king side a
little bit
So I wouldn't want to make this move
unless we were sort of desperate.
Well, not desperate and and really it's
not that weakening
It's really not that weakening because
the dark the light squared bishop for
black is not able to access
key squares g4 and h3
Furthermore after g3
We create this potential idea of knight
to h4 when the knight has access to the
forkable square on g6
g3 I like the look of a little bit more
than rook to e1
Which would be my other candidate move
here in order to meet knight f4 with
bishop f1
Which is another idea that you should
absolutely be fully aware of but I just
don't like the option of allowing the
knight
To land on f4.
So I think we're gonna play more
Drastically here.
Okay.
Our opponent is still playing instantly
and actually not badly at all.
I think i'm
I I wouldn't say that white is more
than very slightly better here
Now the problem is that if we play
knight h4 i'm shocked that our opponent
saw this that quickly
It took me a while
Black can respond with knight to f4 and
that is a typical tactic that occurs
sometimes in king's indian positions
I'll show you after the game knight h4
knight f4 and the pawn on g3 is
overloaded
If we take f4 we lose h4 and of course
the point of knight f4 is to protect
the g6 square
So what I think we should do here is
just continue making
Small but meaningful improvements to
our position
What would those meaningful
improvements look like?
Well, first and foremost, I mean we
could deploy our rook and put it on e1
which I think is a
Relatively risk-free way of improving
our position
Now it has its drawbacks in the form of
weakening the f2 pawn
So if black's queen repositions onto
the f file, we would have to be careful
But black doesn't do that.
He plays knight f6.
We need to continue improving our
position
position one move that I kind of like
is bishop to d3
In order to make space for our queen to
move into e2
Yeah, but but that also puts the bishop
in the line of fire of black's rook
a more
measured positional approach would
involve
Would involve redirecting our bishop to
the fianchetto square on g2
Which would solve the problem of some
of our king side weaknesses
But is a little bit passive
Hmm, not easy.
Actually, this is this guy is incredible.
Let's think about this for a second
Knight h4 also good, but then that
gives up the d4 square
Queen c2 also interesting.
Yeah, I like the look of queen c2 to
develop the queen
But again that runs into knight d4
Again that runs into knight d4 and I
don't love that
it's a weird position and white should
be better here, but
Somehow I don't love it because of this
d4 square
We're struggling because of the
weakness of that square knight f6 is an
amazing move actually
It makes it very hard for me to find a
move
Okay, I guess queen c2 94
94 cd 94.
I don't know why I've been struggling
so much these last few spearing games.
I feel like i'm getting
soundly outplayed
Okay, let's play bishop f1
Let's play bishop f1
And adopt a more defensive posture
bishop e8
Okay queen c1, I guess
Because again, I didn't want to play
queen c2 because it walks into 94 with
tempo
Queen c1 at least if black plays 94 we
have time to react
And we can actually sink our teeth into
e5 as a result
Um, if black plays bishop h5, then I
think okay night g4.
I'm probably getting crushed here
Let's think for a moment bishop g2 was
the idea
Of course, that's the whole point of
why we played bishop f1 in order to get
this bishop to g2
and knight to d4
Okay knight to d4.
I don't find to be scary actually
It looks scary, but I don't think it is
simply because
We can take on d4
I think it's a mistake.
I've and and now
This scenario looks very scary
Now you might be tempted by rook takes
e6 queen takes e6 and bishop to d5
But unfortunately that tactic fails
black can play rook takes d5
and
When the smoke clears black is simply
up a piece
You might also be tempted by knight d5,
but you shouldn't get distracted.
We're trying to defend here knight to
d5
queen
F7 and you can drop the knight to f4,
but it'll be chased away with the move
e5
So again, you want to be defensive here
94 is the move because this defends the
f2 pawn
And on the next move we might chase
black's knight away with h3
Man, I didn't know one could play chess
this fast and this well, but I learn
new things every day
Still I think white is fine.
This is probably equal.
I really don't know where I went wrong
It feels like I made a mistake
somewhere we'll analyze afterward.
This will be a good learning experience
for me as well
So there is a move i'm scared of here.
I won't say what it is
I'll tell you if yes, that is exactly
Okay, um because it threatens bishop
before knight takes f2
All right, so rook e2 d3 rook d2
Okay, i'm in serious danger of losing
this game so i'm gonna focus
Okay, I have an idea let's go queen d2
Let's go queen d2
So here's my idea i'm trying to lure
i'm trying to lure black into playing
bishop takes e4
rook takes e4
Rook takes f2
And then i'm hoping that what black
doesn't see is that when we drop our
queen back, let's say to e1
Black is facing twin threats rook takes
g4
And it's a classic scenario where if
the knight moves the the rook on f2 is
hanging
No black seems to I think our opponent
is totally legit.
I mean
I am getting completely outplayed but
it happens
I'm not mistake free.
I've been saying that since the start
of the speedrun.
I'll probably lose a game
You know one one out of every 500 games
i'm going to get outplayed
So I don't see any reason to be
suspicious yet
Rook takes g2 king takes g2.
No, no, I mean i'll put it this way
If our opponent plays perfectly the
rest of the game
Okay, then we'll we'll look at it.
But so far i've just
I I really I feel like all of my moves
have been very natural and i've gotten
totally outplayed
But that just happens when you make a mistake.
That's just the product to make a
mistake
There is a move here that i'm terrified
of
If our opponent plays it i'll tell you
what it is.
It is a very high level move
It is a very high level move, let's see
if our opponent actually plays it he's
probably calculating bishop takes c4
I won't say the move
Just in case I mean I never say like a
move that scares me just just in case
That's just sort of speed run policy
Yeah, this move causes a lot of
problems
But it doesn't win.
I mean it just it leads to a good
position for black, but it doesn't win
the game immediately
It's not this move I think 95 was big
problems for white
But no that he seems totally legit to
me so far rook takes e4 rook f2
Okay, so he goes for this line
He goes for this line and i'm very
curious what it is that he wants
probably he wants to sack the exchange
after rook takes g2 and go for
I have to record the worders game and
go for
The weakness of our king essentially
At least the start of it, but I have no
choice we have to play queen e1
And rook takes g2, but I don't find
this to be terrifying and there's two
reasons for that
Let me explain the reasons that I don't
find that to be it's scary, but not
terrifying
We can bail out and probably we should
bail out
Probably we should bail out because our
king is permanently weak the knight on
e3 is super strong
Also, I realize the black has knight to
c2
So without question we have to bail out
by playing rook takes e3 and queen
takes e3 and white is not worse here
I refuse to believe that white is worse
Our king is a little bit weaker than
blacks
But black just doesn't have the
material and the fire power to exploit
it queen f6 is an excellent move
So this has been a very humbling
experience for me, but we go queen e2
defending the b2 pawn
And the reason I play queen e2 and not
let's say rook b1 is because rook b1
would be very passive now
We can still try to win this
There's plenty of chess left to be played.
I would be playing this for a win with
black obviously
White should not have any winning
chances here if black plays this
normally
But i've seen crazier things in my
chess career.
So we're gonna i'm gonna try to win
this with white without doing anything
crazy
Without doing anything crazy
So we could try to play rook.
Yeah e5 is another very good move
because rook f1 queen c6 check
is problematic
But let's do it anyway
Anonymous gifting to stockfish
Yeah, very very strong.
I mean I I will say that
When f takes e6 was played I thought
okay, this is going to be a smooth
game, but I greatly underappreciated
that move
I greatly underappreciated the move f
takes e6.
So kudos to our opponent
You know
This is a positional misjudgment by me.
I didn't realize how strong the pawn
was e4
Okay, probably our opponent is just
playing for a win here.
So now I also somehow underestimated
this move
Okay, I guess we have to play b3 to
solidify this pawn
Queen e6 check
Yeah, just getting crushed
Okay, let's think about this queen g4
maybe trying to play for a draw
No, this is simply bad king g2.
He has e3 which I
failed to see
I mean, I will have to go pawn down end
game and try to say and try to hold it
Have to go pawn down quick rook end
game only chance because king g2 e3.
I think was just losing
Maybe not but I didn't want to get
mated
This is borderline lost but there is
some drawing chances in the end game
Actually, they're good drawing.
No.
No, the end game actually might even be
just a draw
I'm not sure but I think it might just
be a draw
And he doesn't wow he goes through but
but if he gets over ambitious here, you
know
You can lose control of a game like
this pretty easily actually
I'm stunned that our opponent didn't
trade queens.
Uh, let's think rookie one
I would take I would take the queen automatically.
I'll put it that way.
Let's try rick f5
Yes, I see how much time he has.
I mean it doesn't take that much time
to outplay me
That's the lesson from this game
Queen e7 queen f4
I'm teetering on the edge.
Essentially.
It's like the dim ding nepo game people
watching on youtube
I'm recording this on the on the day of
the tiebreaker in the world
championship
so in a in a weird way this game
reminds me of nepo ding because
Black has this past pawn and it may not
seem very scary at first sight
But the path for this pawn is totally
clear and we really cannot afford
To consign either of our pieces to a
passive existence on like e2
Because there's too many other problems
to deal with other than the past pawn
So what we have to do is basically
defend actively by which I mean
We have to find tactical methods of
preventing the further progress of the
pawn
I think the move here is queen to f4.
This I think is a good defensive move
Because if black plays e3, I want to
play rookie five
And prevent the further progress of the
pawn
rookie eight
Yeah
Now we have to get behind the pawn
With queen e3, I think
By the way, someone's number of games
does not mean anything at all
But again, I don't see any reason to be suspicious.
I just think he's playing a really good
game
But i'll talk more after the game so
let's play queen e3 let's focus on
holding this
I think I can hold a draw at least if
i'm accurate
i'm accurate now if queen e6 then of
course we want to go g4
And this you should understand if queen
e6 then then we want to go g4
g4
But now I see that queen e6 is very
good
Might be coming to an end.
We'll see
Okay
Rogue d8
Yeah, i'm i'm just i'm getting pushed
off the board here king g2 I have to
step away with my king
I have to step away with my king rook
d3 queen f4.
I'm still trying
Black can easily blunder mate there by
the way very easy to blunder some sort
of rook f8 and queen f5
Lots of games have turned around in
these heavy piece end games because one
side just gets too
And too enamored with like pushing a
pawn and and leaves the king
Exposed or even allows a queen trade
and we would definitely benefit in the
event of a queen trade even at the cost
of a pawn
Even at the cost of a pawn
Okay, no warrior score by the way if
you're watching
I know the game just started but you
will get banned immediately if you
share the warrior score
So, please do not share any numbers at
all
Rogue d1
So rook do you wait a second that
actually looks like a very sloppy move
to me
rook f4
What am I missing?
I mean I surely i'm missing something
because I I get this sometimes get this
feeling of helplessness like
It's too good to be true.
You know, i've been out played the
whole game.
It's funny like I um
Had this with super jibs.
No, but he's he's going astray here.
I think he's giving me
He's letting me off the hook pretty
easy
He's focused on the wrong pawn so
The question now is well, we have three
things that we can do if I want to get
really gutsy
Then we should play a4 and actually try
to keep my queenside pawns
That's if I want to play for the win,
then i'll go a4
The problem with a4 is that he goes
rook a2 check and I can very easily get
mated so I don't
The point of the speedrun is to do what
I would do in a real game
And in a real game, I wouldn't even
think about playing a4
I would immediately take on e4 and i'll
show you some lines after the game
That are scaring me.
Now, what would I take on e4 with?
Well, I would want to take with a piece
that increases my chances of a queen
trade
Because the queen trade is the fastest
path to withdraw from this position if
that makes sense and to me
Well, obviously that would be queen
takes e4
Rook takes e4 would be the all-in move.
I would play in bullet
But rook take I think rook takes e4
would be more appealing to some people
because you see that you can deliver a
check on e8
But if you look concretely after rook
takes e4 black can play queen c6
And pin the rook against the king also
black will of course start by playing
rook takes a2 check
And maybe there we could have played
king h3.
Yeah, maybe that was an interesting
attempt to play for the win.
I I didn't
Appreciate that fully
Yeah, but okay.
It's fine
Okay, now king g3 or king I didn't see
that we could even go king h3
But here it doesn't make sense to go
king h3
Because if we're preparing for an end
game, we want our king to be as close
as possible to the center
So am I not afraid of queen to d6 here
pinning the rook against the king?
Okay
Now it should be a draw
But that doesn't mean we can't win this
i've won some crazy end games before
and if our opponent gets very sloppy
This is a winnable position now
At this point i'm gonna try to play for
a win.
I'm gonna try to do everything within
my power
To make our opponent go wrong.
And the first thing i'm gonna do
Is play the move c5
Which is a very tricky move and if
black responds inaccurately he is
already in trouble
And he responds very accurately.
I actually missed this move or does he?
Yeah, he does
Okay.
Now let's go rook d4 and try to get the
rook to the seventh
I completely missed a5
For some reason, I mean it's a
straightforward move because it
prevents rook b4
And that's another very good move.
Okay, so I guess i'm not out of the
woods just yet.
Let's let's uh, yeah
I'm still the one playing for a draw
here
Because there's a crazy line rook d6
rook a3 rook b6 a4
And this this defensive task it never
ends
Yeah, I guess i'm still in trouble here
Just not used to this
Okay king f4, I guess
It was not obvious at all actually a5
to stop like stop it like that with a
pawn
Was was was far from an obvious move
far from an obvious move
I mean the amount of things I feel like
i'm missing in this game are like
incredible
It's hard to say if i'm playing
terribly or if he's playing extremely
well probably both okay, let's go rook
d6
We'll see we'll see we'll check the
accuracy and stuff.
I mean he has made mistakes there's no
question that yet
He has made mistakes
Obviously he's made mistakes
Um, but overall i've gotten totally
outplayed here king e5
Let's try to activate my king and get
this rook to b6 in order to draw this
Okay
Yeah, I see where this is going
No, we're not drawing this.
Unfortunately, I didn't see this move
either
Let's try this last last hope
Last hope
I mean if I could go c6, it's still it
still could be holdable
Against the you know
A club player but a gm should be able
to beat me here
Rook d2 rook b2.
That's maybe that's bad.
No
Let's think
Wait, that's probably not a good move
rook d3.
He allows me to step back with my rook
in order to vacate
A square for my kings.
It's not over.
It's far from over rook g2
Okay, now I just legitimately have to
be very accurate
Okay, I guess rook d4 to define I mean
I cannot give away a second pawn
If I give away this pawn then he gets
connected passers and it's over the
game is over
The good thing is I don't have to wait
very long for his move so the torture
won't last very long
Rook g3 b4.
No rook g3 b4.
That's not winning.
I mean that's a trap
That I laid of course, he's not gonna
fall for it
Maybe he will we'll see
Rook g3 b4
I want to play
So i'll talk a little bit about the
nature of like suspicion after the game
right now
My verdict is that he is legit
And I would say if I was suspicious I
have
I have said it before I will say it
again
I truly genuinely think for now that
he's playing honestly.
He's just clearly clearly underrated
Okay, so let's focus on trying to save
this
But i'm not sure of course, i'm not
sure this entirely I would not be
surprised, but I don't believe he is
Uh, let's go king d6
I don't really know much about chess
and people so if you think you know
better then I guess you know better
Let's go king d6
I think this might be drawable
actually, but he finds king d8
That's a great move
I'm just getting this total feeling of
hopelessness
Which I shouldn't be getting but I am
getting it
I mean c6 maybe is a draw
c6
Let me think c6 bc rook a4
Is an interesting idea by the way
No, it should be a draw.
Let's go see let's go c6
Yeah, he does find a lot of good moves,
okay bc
Rook a4 king c8 king c6
Maybe it's lost
Okay
Hopefully he doesn't play king c8 and
he gives me the check on d3 then I have
some maybe
Okay, does give me the check on d3
Let's see why that is better
It should be a draw, I mean there's
there's no way this should be winning
Okay, let's go king b7 and then try to
go b6
Now wait a second this I I mean I know
it's funny, but you know
If he's not careful I can play b6 and
king a7 and b7
So
I've seen many situations many of these
types of end games where
People just get super flustered and
lose
Okay, that's a good move.
I think
Okay, let's go here actually very
tricky move i'm gonna make king b8
The point is just to roll out the red
carpet for the pawn and the great thing
about this for white
Is that once I get my pawn to b7 and
i'm actually gonna play for the win
here
No, but it's once we get the pawn to b7
Then this king on a7 is going to be
unassailable because this rook on a4
Is stopping black from delivering
checks on the a file.
I'm already playing for a win.
I'm gonna go king a6
Now I think he obviously black can draw
this with super accurate play.
I already think black is playing for a
draw
And black has a very difficult move here.
I see it.
I think it draws
But this already might be the only move
and he doesn't play what I the move I
thought it was
So now we go b6
And if king c8 king a7 and we're almost
winning
It's probably still a draw though
We're very close to being winning here
King a7
But probably unfortunately still a draw
sag
Yeah, he finds it he finds it okay,
basically actually wait, maybe am I
losing
No, I see a draw I think
Check well that move obviously, wait a second.
Wait up.
Hold up
There's some cool lines here
rook c1 a2
Nah, shoot doesn't work
I I think I have to go b7 because if I
go rook a4 he can actually start
playing for a win with king c6
so I think
I need to go b7
If my king was on a8 it would be
winning
And he finds a2 yeah, I mean there's
nothing to find here
Yeah, I'm king c7
Perfectly executed but this is a draw
which I am very happy with I have to
say
I'm proud to make this draw
Because this guy was an absolute
monster
And we'll check I mean obviously here
we should analyze with the engine
because okay he's playing for it wait
Wait, let's not celebrate just yet
Now wait a second did that lose no rook
c1 he's got rook a3
uh
So close
Okay, but if he goes if he gets too
cute, okay draw
I guess it is a draw
It is a draw.
Yeah, and he found only moves
Um, okay gg gg
The path forward from 2000 is is filled
with uh trials and tribulations.
All right, let's analyze
So we will check his accuracy obviously
not trying to imply anything just
because people in the chat are curious
My accuracy was probably pathetic
It was 94.3 to 94.7.
Okay, that's pretty high actually for
both of us
So I did not play terribly.
That's your answer to the question
I did not play terribly
Here's the proof
Okay, that is some high accuracy for
sure
I feel like gada komski here
Now a couple of words because this is
an extremely touchy subject
and people on youtube
Especially I found get can get very
emotional about
The situation where a gm or somebody
with a platform
essentially just without proper
judgment or consideration is
Essentially implying that if anybody
lower rated than them beats them their
ego can't take it
So by definition someone is cheating
Now here's what I have to say on that
Of course when a gm is playing an fm in
three plus zero
It's unacceptable to just go around and
start throwing out accusations
Now it's a different situation the more
the higher the rating disparity the
less likely it becomes that in a longer
game
You know, for example if a 1500 beats
me in a 15 minute game and i'm playing
completely seriously
By definition that is probably
suspicious unless I had a mouth slip or
I blundered a queen if i'm playing my
strength
For a 1600 or even a 2000 to play like
a 2600 for the entirety of the game
If it's not some sort of opening
theory, you know or some forced draw
is
Suspicious by definition, which doesn't
mean that the person is necessarily cheating.
It's just statistically unlikely
Hopefully people can understand that
phrase is not very controversial
So the game has to be investigated more
carefully
If the accuracy is like 95
You know 2000s rarely attain that so
you have to take the game consider the
game very seriously
The other thing that struck out to me
was how quickly my opponent was playing
which was almost instantly
and the other thing that stuck out to
me was the
Feeling I got that no matter what I did
my opponent had an accurate response
prepared
So I definitely got those feelings i'm
not gonna lie
I had those feelings of helplessness
that I often get when I feel like i'm
getting
You know when i'm playing a guide
Um, so am I a little bit just a little
bit suspicious?
Yes, and hopefully I don't get burned
to the stake for saying that
It wouldn't be acceptable to just bury
my opponent and say he's cheating for
sure
more than unacceptable
um, so hopefully we can
We can toe that line and we can look at
the game with an engine
And a couple of the critical moments.
I want to see if in fact they were top
engine moves
That's going to be the goal and we're
going to look at the game and try to
learn from it.
That's the main goal
it's no
Okay, I I can tell that some people
haven't listened to a single word that
I said
Because you're saying isn't
statistically unlikely just a fancy way
to name cheaters
No, it statistically unlikely means
statistically unlikely.
It means it happens from time to time
But if it happens it needs to be
investigated carefully, that's all it
means
And no, I know some people are going to
be listening to this thing
Yeah, he actually thinks this guy
cheated for sure.
He's just putting on a face.
No
I truly do not know.
I promise I swear.
I I honestly do not know what to think
You know because part of me is saying
yeah, like I just got totally outplayed
by 2000
The other part of me is like I probably
didn't play that well
And get over it
Okay
Here we go
So the opening we have faced before
bishop e2
This line with d4
Has been played by a lot of gms, but
it's not particularly great c5 is the
top move
So c5 is the uh is the top engine
choice
Apparently, this is the way to fight
the line.
See I never knew that because in my day
everybody would play bishop f5
And then after knight f3 white is a
modest a small and modest advantage
So for the purpose.
Yeah for the purposes of this analysis.
I will turn on
I will turn on uh the hs.com engine
All right, so you can see here that
it's like point two.
I mean, it's it's a very modest
advantage
It's a very modest advantage
But I like white's position.
I mean, this is relatively easy to play
castles
Black can play knight before in such
positions
But you can always go knight a3 and
then chase the knight away with c3
So c5 is a is a great move here because
it immediately contests white's center
immediately contests white's center
So we decided on playing c4
The knight drops back to f6 and d5
Okay, so e6 is obvious and very good
pawn takes e6.
Yeah, so here I I simply
Fail to understand that pawn takes e6
is so strong.
Hopefully I can be forgiven for that
I operated out of general principles.
I thought this was a very bad move
because this pawn is very weak
I mean just visually it looks very
ugly, but I think there are two factors
that contributed to my mis-evaluation
The first one is what I mentioned in a
bit
Which is that black has this idea of
ensconcing a knight on d4
And because we don't have an e pawn and
because our c pawn is on c4 white is
going to permanently have problems
Sorry, white is going to permanently
have problems with the d4 square.
My bad
White is going to permanently have
problems
With it with the d4 square
The second thing is of course the
semi-open f file, which I also
experience problems with much like in
openings like the vienna
You get the f file which you can use to
attack
Black's king and it's a one-way street
because one side does have a pawn on
the f file and the other side doesn't
And while not having a pawn on the f
file can be considered a drawback
Here our pieces are not active enough
to punish black for that it's more of a
strength
Uh, so bishop takes c6
I correctly evaluated and I thought
that this was quite a bit better for
white
Uh, and it is I mean we're gonna play
bishop e3 and queenside castle
You know, but given how obscure bishop
e2 is I really would doubt that this is
theory
So our opponent plays f takes c6 very
instructive knight c6 knight f3 bishop
e7 castles castles
This is all very normal bishop to g5
Apparently already, you know white is
struggling to equalize h6 good move
Bishop h4 and again, I completely
midnight h5 to me was not intuitive at
all
because in my eyes
Black is essentially leaving himself
with a bad bishop
What I fail to appreciate is that this
knight coming to f4 is just an
incredibly strong idea best move
Bishop e7 queen e7 already probably
white is slightly worse
So g3 I made a very good move here
second move according to the engine the
top engine move here was bishop to d3
And bishop e4 so this is a little bit
computerish, but keeping the bishop
this way would have kept equality
So g3 is a move that we played
essentially out of desperation because
I was so worried about the knight
coming into f4
rook ad a good move
rookie one
Okay, and knight f6 another move that
did not occur to me at all
Okay, i'm starting to get a little bit suspicious.
I will be completely and totally honest
here
But knight f6 to me is not intuitive
because I felt like black really wants
to go knight f4
And also it's very important to foresee
that after knight h4 black has knight
to f4
Black has knight to f4.
Yeah because of the speed that's why
i'm a little bit suspicious
Because these moves are taking black 15
to 17 seconds.
These are extremely high level moves
bishop f1
bishop e8
queen c1
knight g4
Bishop g2.
Oh, so knight d4 is the top move.
Okay, 94 which I thought was a mistake.
But of course, what do I know?
takes takes 94
bishop c6
Is not accurate
Or it is accurate.
Sorry.
It's one of the top moves
Uh bishop c6 is a good move
Queen to d2.
I mean i'm defending very well now here.
I think black made a mistake
Here our opponent thought for a while
for two minutes and made a serious
mistake
Of course the best move as I had
indicated is knight g4 to e5
And the reason this move is so strong
The reason this move is so strong is
because the knight is heading for f3
Now why is knight f3 such a strong idea
well because it eliminates the only
defensive piece on the king side
Here for example if white plays b3 and
after knight f3 check as you can see
this is a very nasty position
I would even estimate this as more than
minus point seven because you can see
how weak the light squares are on the
king side
So very instructive retreating move
knight e5 and knight f3
Of course if white tries to cover the
f4 f3 square, then you give up a pawn
on c4 and the knight jumps into e3
so it's uh
It's a good idea to file into your
mental directory
So bishop takes e4 kind of lets us off
the hook, but then our opponent follows
up very accurately rook f2
Of course, I did not see uh the fact
that the knight is heading for c2
And I correctly decided to take on e3
knight c2 here
Is winning for black?
Rookie six queen f8 and you're gonna
lose the rook on a1 and the pawn is
just gonna run forward
so
This was the correct decision by me.
But once again, I start getting
outplayed queen e2 e5
Rook f1 queen c6 and already it's a
little bit worse king h3 e4
Yeah b3 i'm still playing very
accurately here queen g4 queen e5
Um rook f5 is probably a step in the
wrong direction now queen f4 is a
slight inaccuracy because of rook e8
now queen e6
rook d8
Yeah, still i'm holding equality
I'm still playing almost perfectly
But somewhere here I made a mistake
Yeah c5 is still equal
But I had to find b4
I didn't think the oh
I saw b4
Which leads to immediate liquidation
But I forgot that after rook a4
instructive moment
Ba obviously blunders the rook but you
get the rook onto a square with check
then you play ba
Then you play ba
And uh, it's a draw
I mean it just it's just mutual
liquidation and a two on two when all
is said and done
The point is I forgot that you can move
the rook onto a defended square
Now what was the idea of the move c5?
I actually think this was a very
ingenious research
Uh research, why did I say that word?
Resource resource.
Yeah, that's why that's why I misspoke.
I was like what word was I planning to say?
Okay resource now it makes sense.
Uh, it was an ingenious resource
Because if black plays rook b2, which I
think is a move a lot of people would
make rook b4
And white wins a pawn like you defend
and simultaneously you attack and now
you see why I put the pawn on c5
So that b6 can be met with cb same
thing
By the way after rook a3 you go rook b4
and white is already playing for a win
But somehow I forgot the black can just
stop it with a5
rook d4
And another very I could king e8 not
king e7 as I would have played but king
e8, of course
king f4
rook h2
rook f2 check
rook c2
Rook b2 is an inaccuracy, I guess
Rook c3 was the move
Which to me is pretty intuitive rook
c3, but I was planning king d6 and
apparently black is close to winning
here
Okay, uh, let's see if I defend it
accurately rook b2 rook d3 rook g2
Rook g3 and already this lets me off
the hook due to b4 here for sure our
opponent is
Yeah, this is I mean this is quite easy
to draw at this point
But still no already like already black
has to be very accurate
Black has to be very accurate here
Yeah, I mean it was a game played on a
grand master level by black.
That's all i'm gonna say the game was
played
At a gm level
So if it's a smurf
Then I believe it if it's someone
extremely underrated.
I believe it otherwise.
I don't really believe it
And of course, there are more advanced
tools to checking.
I would especially
Look at my opponent's other games
But the time consumption for such a
game of this quality is crazy
I mean the guy has to be ultra talented.
He let he ended the game with 12 23
He really only thought on one move
funnily enough.
That move was the only mistake of the
game
Okay, there were some inaccuracies
By the way, the reason you play king e8
here and not king to e7 is because
Is because well his other games are on
this level clearly is because here
white plays rook d6
And the point is after rook a3 rook b6
a4
Rook takes b7 is a check
Now compare this to the king e8 line.
I was wanting to play rook d6
But I realized that if you follow the
same line
This is not a check black plays rook
takes b3 check and wins the game on the
spot
Because this forces a rook trade and as
a consequence the pawn rolls down to
promotion
So something that would probably take
me, you know a minute to appreciate it
took our opponent 15 seconds, but it's
pretty consistent
With his play if king e6 instead this
is even worse because here the rook
gets to b6 with tempo
No, i'm sure I mean he's if he's had an
account for years then he's legit
But it's just I mean again, hopefully
even if you're my opponent and you're
watching this
Surely you can see why i'm starting to
get suspicious about this game
A lot of games a lot of moves on on a
super gm level for sure
so conclusions from this game and we
didn't analyze it quite as
Diligently as I normally would analyze
a speedrun game
You know sometimes this this deflating
feeling it makes it hard for me to
analyze
The rest of the games look nothing like
this apparently.
Yeah, so first of all
D4 c5 was ultra accurate opening play
Ultra accurate opening play every move
about 15 seconds
Then f takes e6 is a super gm move
right here.
I
This is a move that shows a very high
level understanding of the position
then
Then of course super accurate play in
the middle game knight h5 was a nice
move rook d8 bishop e8
94 94.
I mean just perfect play in the middle
game
Then the one mistake which was uh not
to play 95 which was to take on e4 but
that was followed up by
Another ultra accurate sequence of
moves like every one of these moves was
the most testing
I held my ground very nicely.
I thought
Until I played c5.
This is where I started playing for a
win and the moment I start playing for
a win
I get into some trouble
Black plays well
And of course it would have been more
trouble if black had played in this
position
Either king to e7 which to me was one
of the most intuitive moves of the
whole game
To just bring the king up and prevent
white's king from accessing d6
But instead rook b2
allowed us to drop the rook back to d3
which opened up more pathways for our
king
and
Okay, b4 was an accurate defensive move
and I was able to hold the game
So I thought it was a well defended
game
I could feel pretty early that we were
dealing with a very serious opponent.
I had that feeling
You know again
You know when these come out on
youtube, there's always
A buzz in the comment section
And there's always some people who are
going to be like who are going to feel
like i'm unfairly
Judging my opponent or i'm not giving
you the benefit of the doubt.
I am i'm not going to report him
i'm going to take a closer look at the
game on my own
and if I feel that it's getting more
and more obvious then
You know that I might
I also i'm doing a speed run and
obviously i'm not
uh
You know, i'm also smurfing
So I don't think it's really my place
to report people in the speed run
Uh unless unless it's ultra blatant
cheating
Okay
I hope you enjoyed the analysis.
I'm going to get going and watch the
game
And uh, I might be back tonight if i'm
feeling energetic.
I'll be back tonight
Thank you everybody for the support and
for being
Very wholesome, you know with the 105
subs today.
It was a massive sub day.
So thank you everybody
Uh, very very much particularly anur
for all of your support through the
months
And velvet canyon.
Thank you for the five subs earlier as well.
I will raid
Who will I raid?
Let's read costia.
Let's read costia
And and keep the chess education
content going.
See you guys later
Uh, thanks again and goodbye